I think tonight's topic is one that
we've revisited in a number of different
angles and I think it's increasingly
important in the world where it's hard
to even know the filter that we are
seeing the world through increasingly
and I know actually just looking through
the tonight's list of people that that
came that many of you are working on the
algorithms that we're talking about so
I'm especially interested to hear your
responses and questions to tonight's
talk and with that I'm gonna hand you
off to probably a presenter who's
presented two more numbers of humans
than anybody else he's brought he's I
think working in newsrooms and in front
of all kinds of different audiences and
talking to all kinds of technologists I
think in a much broader spectrum then
most of our speakers ever get a chance
to do so
welcome Jacob or thank you so much
Thank You Xander I really appreciate it
before I start I do want to sort of
shout out casbahs this Center for
Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences they right now are accepting
applications for fellowships and all
manner of people wind up getting to be
there including even lowly journalists
like myself and so I really recommend it
if you have the opportunity if you are
in any way connected to academia and any
sense and could use a year it's an
incredible experience so I highly
recommend it
I I work in news I'm an NBC News
correspondent and the sort of day-to-day
of the grind of that means that my
attention span is like this a lot of the
time and so it's a wonderful opportunity
to be here tonight with all
view in such a thoughtful environment
that is devoted to thinking of things in
so much longer and more civilized
timeframes than I typically get to in my
workday and so it's wonderful to be able
to sort of step back from all of that
and talk about this stuff with you so
I'm gonna start this with something that
that I have thought about a lot sort of
in my kind of earlier life as a
publisher of sorry as a magazine editor
at popular science magazine when we were
at popular science we would go deep on
certain subjects that were sort of they
became almost sort of like intellectual
kind of comfort food and one of the big
ones for us was interplanetary transit
getting from here to another planet and
I know that a lot of you probably have
thought about this as well but in this
case we thought a lot about Mars right
getting to Mars okay let's talk about
you know how would we get there how
could you possibly get across those
incredible distances because you know
the transit takes 300 days at least
depending on the the relationship of the
two bodies to one another you know where
they're having their orbits and so how
could you across that incredible
distance in incredible time have a human
crew get all the way to the Red Planet
and survivor and how would they survive
the rigors of deep space the radiation
could they communicate back you know and
could they you know even get along
during that period of time and they've
in fact been these very interesting
experiments in which first in Russia and
recently more easily in Hawaii they
actually made cosmonauts and astronauts
sit in the frickin thing for the amount
of time that you would have them
actually transfer from our planet to
Mars and just see if they don't drive
each other crazy and sure enough every
time they would drive each other [ __ ]
crazy right in the in the Russian one
it's actually not very well reported
that they that they actually had a case
of sexual harassment maybe assault
somebody got punched in the nose like
you know it went wrong and so the idea
that we could even get 300 days through
space to another planet we're almost
certainly the first crew will die right
they're never coming back is one of
these things it just boggles the mind
well you then think about
so planets okay let's think about how
far away the nearest survivable planet
is really a survival one not like Mars
where you could stand there and hold
your breath and make it for you know a
couple minutes but one where you could
in theory stand and breathe some sort of
atmosphere you know it might work out
right so for people who don't know
exoplanets has this notion that that
people have found mostly through
something called the Kepler mission that
was its data coming back where we're a
distant star has some sort of
intervening objects that we can just
barely detect because the light from
that distant star gets bent around it
and by doing that bending you can tell
the size the proportion the distance
from the star that that planet is and
therefore we go oh it might be in the
same sort of proportion as Earth and
thus it might be a breathable atmosphere
anyway all of it is conjecture but it
does suggest to people that there are
some places that we might be able to
live elsewhere in our galaxy so this is
the closest exoplanet to earth Proxima
Centauri B and it's only 4.2 light years
away when they discovered this it was
this just like you know people were just
like wow we are going to this planet
we're gonna swim in its oceans we're
playing volleyball on the beaches let's
go but then because I work a part of
science we ruin these sorts of ideas
very quickly by doing the math on what
it would take to get there so it turns
out that at the top speed of a rocket
that we can currently make which is
about twenty thousand miles an hour it
would take 137 thousand years to get to
Proxima Centauri be the closest detected
livable planet in our galaxy so that is
about 2,000 human generations to get
there and that has spawned a tiny little
group at NASA that thinks about
something called the generation ship and
it would in fact be a vessel that you
would have to get on board you somehow
have enough people and enough genetic
diversity in that first group of people
to get onboard that they mate they have
a whole other generation right and 1900
and then nine
nine generations later when we all have
eyes in the center of our foreheads and
our ears are down here or God knows
what's happened to you genetically right
but terrible things have happened over
the intervening time for you to all be
living in the same freaking tin can for
2,000 generations 137 thousand years to
put that in context human beings walked
off of Africa like for the first time we
went beyond just full-on survival mode
and into thinking like what else is
there in the world and walked off of
Africa only a hundred and forty thousand
years ago you know everyone here is part
of a species that really has only been
upright and thinking for about a hundred
and forty thousand years you think about
all of that being contained in this one
thing and I'll just tell you right now
the fundamental conclusion here is we
are not going to another planet that's
not happening there's no way that's
gonna happen because 137 thousand years
mm you know it's long that's a long time
and instead we need to start thinking
about this ship our ship that we are on
right now this is it is the only one we
get right we're on the ship and we need
to start thinking in terms of
generations the way this little time
this little group of NASA people is
thinking about it and one of the things
that I think is so sort of fundamental
that we need to start thinking about is
it's a really fragile little arrangement
you know there's a lot of sexual
harassment and sexual assault going on
in this ship you know there's a lot of
stuff going badly and we need to be
careful of what we set loose on the
decks of this ship and I find that one
of the ones that's bothering me the most
you know I think is the most worrisome
is artificial intelligence and it is the
ways in which we are going to set it
loose on the crew in a way that I think
is going to have terrible consequences
if we're not careful in not maybe not
this generation maybe not the next but a
couple generations down some bad stuff
could happen and that's what I want to
talk about here tonight so we are
building guidance systems that shape our
choices I think fundamentally and we're
doing it without any realization of not
only how effective they're going to be
on us but also the singular human
characteristics that make us both
vulnerable to
and totally unconscious that they're
working on us and for me I think this is
a really important thing for us to start
thinking about so before I get into that
let's talk a little bit about what the
[ __ ] is machine learning
because it's something that I think a
lot of people don't really understand
I'm sure and this crew almost all of you
understand it in some way but you have
to take the Ripper you know the remarks
that I've prepared here tonight so I'm
just gonna go ahead and walk through
this the way I have been explaining it
to people and I'll be curious tonight to
have anybody here sort of help me refine
this I'm trying to get better at it is
you have a big amount of messy data you
know what to do with it you don't want
to pay people to go through it you don't
have to sit yourself and go through it
so instead you find comparable data
training data that in some way has
either direct application to the data
you're looking at it's like a tiny
subset of it or it's close enough of a
parallel that it might be useful in some
way you use that to then create
basically examples of right and wrong
answers that you can give to an
algorithm and then using those right
wrong examples instead of just straight
coding instructions you can then turn
that algorithm loose to apply the rules
that is learned on the messy data that
you started with so here's an example of
how that might work let's say you want
to ask an algorithm okay algorithm tell
me which is which which is a cow and
which is a dog tell me the difference
between these two things in a bunch of
photographs I'm about to give you or you
know in some other piece of you know
some data that's full of cows and dogs
tell me the difference between these two
things if you give the system enough
cows and tell it this is these are
correct pictures of cows and you give it
enough pictures of dogs and say these
are actually dogs you can in fact teach
it enough examples that it can draw the
distinction between the two the AI uses
patterns to label the data that's really
all it comes down to so when you think
about it in terms of just a system that
just is trying to draw a distinction
between categories you really begin to
understand that it doesn't actually know
anything beyond the basic barest minimum
it needs to distinguish between those
two things so let's say that in a bunch
of data you've got on cows and dogs
there were two variables you can look at
there's size and there's slobber
right it picks those out says oh here's
here's one that's really consistent in
the examples you've given me and out of
that it can begin charting oh the dogs
fall into the slobber category and
they're a little smaller in size here's
the cows they're bigger they slumber
some but not too much and out of that
you can draw this line that
distinguishes between the two this one
is dogs sorry this one is cows decide
dogs you're just teaching it how to
distinguish between the two people think
that they're I think sort of the
misperception among the the you know
many many people that I talk to tends to
be that there's something more
sophisticated going on in this but
really it is just describing the
difference machine learning really just
uses the patterns to just draw that
distinguishing line that's really all it
comes down to so I think that for me
that was so important to understand is
that it doesn't really know anything
about dogs or cows it just knows the
simplest possible way to tell the
difference based on the data you've
given it so now the problem that I'm
trying to identify here is that human
beings are all about patterns that's all
we do is fall into patterns you point a
camera at drunk people at a hockey game
they're always gonna do this every time
right you put the words kiss-cam
underneath they're gonna kiss each other
we are incredibly predictable as a
species it's just what we do and so it's
my nightmare by the way that someday I'm
gonna be in this you know talk like this
and those people are gonna somehow be in
the audience because I have no idea who
they are you know but like they totally
look like my contemporaries and they
could be out there somewhere so anyway
someday that'll happen so the question
that I sort of am playing with is if you
look across all the patterns of human
behavior is there any category of human
behavior that you couldn't pick patterns
out of or is all of it readable by an
algorithm is any behavior random right
or is every piece of behavior somehow
readable by an algorithm in the same way
they can distinguish between dogs and
cows so here's an example of one that
seems very random but it turns out an
algorithm can pick patterns up like that
and it is
divorce so half of us couples break up
divorce between 40 to 50 percent
depending on who on the studies you're
looking at and it turns out that there
are in fact very consistent reasons that
are cited for why they split up the
stressors in the relationship are super
consistent at least in this culture
money time children are the top three
factors typically cited and as a result
there is a whole industry of mediation
apps that are growing up and one of them
that I've been dealing with a lot we're
about to do a story on it for NBC as a
company called co-parent er that is
fascinating what they've basically done
is discovered that because the sort of
the the catalysts for fights tend to
come through on the text messages
exchanged between a newly divorced
couple as they're trying to negotiate
over the co-parenting of a kid they've
actually found that there are 700 to 900
words and phrases that indicate trouble
is coming and so when couples are
ordered by a judge to use the app in
their communications with one another as
over 100 family courts around the
country have began to do then you write
to your wife you know you start to say
to your ex-wife I'll never give you
another dime you lying but you know
whatever and it pops up literally a
little warning pops up and says are you
sure you want to send this text message
because based on what we see here you're
probably going to wind up back in court
are you sure right so when we talk to
the and and not only sorry not only does
it spot the disagreements as they're
coming up it also even spots the
opportunities for an agreement so when
you start to say well why don't you pick
him up every Friday or whatever the
thing is it'll say it looks like you're
about to come up with a scheduling
agreement why don't we give you this
draft template where you guys can agree
to this sign it maybe if you'd like to
it'll propose solutions because again
we're not random we're totally full of
patterns human beings or at least
Americans fight in this way in this
super consistent way that an algorithm
can spot just as easily as they can tell
the difference between size and slobber
so for me I think it's fascinating
because it has tremendous short-term
benefit right supposedly according to
the company but but this is backed up by
court by the courts eighty-five percent
of couples who use this settle their
differences out of court and never
return to a judge again that's it
they're they're totally helped by it and
the people that we've interviewed who
have used it say it's fabulous we don't
get into the same fights we do our
communications are incredibly brief and
to the point we're really getting along
the way we never could before
great my problem is will the kid who's
never seen his parents
settle it without a robot mediator as a
result be consigned to a lifetime of
always requiring that coach to be in the
middle of that conversation right you
can imagine the sitcom version of this
right we're a suburban family right is
being coached all through their day
about how to be with one another and
then it breaks down and everything goes
wrong I have a whole like the whole
treatment for a sitcom written written
about this you know generationally for
me what will it be like when everyone
has grown up on a guided solution like
this and doesn't know how to wing it
without it down the line so before we go
any further than this I want to talk a
little bit about this question of again
you know these are not as sophisticated
a set of algorithms as we think they are
at least as other people outside this
room perhaps think they are and so I
think the fundamental question is is
does the technology actually know us or
instead are we programmed hardwired
somehow to believe that it does more
than it does and as businesses grow
around them are we going to be further
and further incentivized to promote and
believe the idea that these things are
really really good at everything so for
me the good cautionary tale that I think
everybody has sort of should know about
is Joseph Weizenbaum he was an early
creator of what was at the time
essentially the first chatbot he built a
a system a sort of a script a decision
tree script that would kick back pre
scripted answers depending on what you
had
written literally into a teletype system
and he was trying to figure out what to
do with it and how to sort of use it in
an experimental way and so what he
decided to do was he would dress it up
as what was cool at the time which was a
Rogerian therapist and it was the kind
of therapy that was in fashion at the
time of where they reflect your answers
back at you and so he he made it such
that he could sit his secretary in front
of it in his first experiment and have
her type in certain inputs he'd say talk
to it the way you would to a therapist
and she goes okay well my boyfriend's
driving me crazy and the computer says
why is your boyfriend driving you crazy
well you know how men are well how our
men tell me that you know he you in fact
you remind me of my boyfriend a bit why
do you think I remind you of your
boyfriend right it's just reflecting it
back within five minutes she had turned
around to him and said I need you to
leave the room I can't have you here
this is far too sensitive a conversation
this is a this is private within two
years the American Psychological
Association had predicted the end of
human therapy and the rise of robot
therapist Carl Sagan stood up on
television and said that's it robot
therapists are happening it's all coming
this is happening why isn't mom quit the
field his response to this and this is
amazing cuz I tell I tell roomful of
young entrepreneurs about this and they
go what do you mean he quit the field
why did he do that he had a great
product going he was ready to rock you
know which I always go oh you're all
we're all in such trouble that you have
that reaction right but basically he
said human beings should not have this
kind of technology we should not be
using it to trick one another like this
we are too gullible we are too
inherently vulnerable to believing that
this stuff can do more than it can and
so he died in Germany as an
environmental activist spent the rest of
his life
agitated for better treatment of the
planet but that has not stopped the
progress of people who do want to use
our susceptibility for using this stuff
to do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] but in my
French and we're not just using it to
decipher our tastes right we're not
using it to just do sort of
recommendation engines you know on
Spotify we're using it to do all kinds
of stuff and I know you probably can't
read most
sort of intended just to try and hit you
over the head with the idea that
billions of dollars are being spent in
government and in private industry to
turn AI to all sorts of crazy uses we
just interviewed I don't can't talk
about that but we talked we've talked to
a girl talk to a large number of people
doing really creepy stuff with AI in all
areas of life not just the fun stuff but
you know it is fundamentally who gets a
job who gets a loan who goes to jail
that stuff is starting to get sorted out
by the same algorithms that just draws
lines between categories so what's wrong
with that well I get it it's faster it's
more efficient it also I think takes
away a certain amount of sort of human
horror when it comes to having to make
difficult choices just gotta get this
job as this guy get this loan she's not
getting well you know computer said so
no big deal and I I'm not sort of making
this up this is happening now so you
guys probably remember back in 2017 on
United flight three four one one a group
of passengers the whole plane was asked
who here can get off the flight we're
oversold we're overbooked somebody's got
to get off this flight and no one
volunteered because they didn't offer
enough money they said it was like 400
bucks or somebody got off the last
flight out that night nobody volunteered
and so they said okay well if no one
will volunteer we're gonna choose and
people at random and what they didn't
tell people is that a computer chose the
names at random when they came back
having said so three people who were
chosen said okay we were chosen at
random we're out no problem and they got
up and they got off but a guy named
David down pulmonologist said I can't I
can't get off the flight you've chosen
me I get it
but I have rounds in the morning I have
you know patients with heart failure I
got to see in the morning there is no
way I'm getting off this flight and in
fact he was invoking what he didn't know
at the time was a legal right on his
part you're not allowed to pull a
physician on call off a flight but the
gate agent and the
people in charge of that flight
basically abandoned all their human
faculties and said computer chose this
guy get him off the flight they got
security guards in to get him off the
flight and they [ __ ] him up right they
pulled him off the flight such that they
they broke a bones in his body he was
hospitalized afterwards right and what
people don't know is the guards the
security personnel who were called in to
do that are now actually suing United
and the FAA and it's funny when you look
at coverage of that in in in mainstream
media they they talk a look out I can't
believe I use that term in public never
mind that can I somehow I wish I could
erase that mainstream media forget it
the coverage of that at the time was
very mocking of these security guards
saying how they you know they're suing
of course they're suing you know America
isn't it screwed up well their argument
was in fact we were instructed to do a
thing that we were not trained to make
decisions about right and in in essence
what they were sort of saying was no one
there told us to make any other decision
we were told the computer has chosen
this guy and it had because of whatever
his frequent flyer status how recently
he had bought the ticket who knows what
the various variables were that caused
the computer chose these four names but
for whatever reason it turned off
everyone's humanity and turned up the
just certainty of the situation such
that they do something terrible to a guy
in front of all these other passengers
you know something that you never do now
now in retrospect it looks ridiculous
and now United's policy is to blow you
know throw all kinds of money at you in
fact my wife and I flew for free to on a
vacation a couple weeks later because
the second that they said we're gonna
need volunteers to get off a flight
there's totally done relay
they were gonna throw as much money as
they needed at us and sure enough you
know we got like thousands of dollars
right away because they knew you don't
do this anymore in fact what you should
do is give more money for more money and
then people will volunteer and walk away
and you don't get into this kind of
trouble
so the abandoning of
our you know human choices is something
that I'm really worried about here and
it's true not just in the sort of hard
and fast you know who goes and who stays
stuff it's it's it's making its way into
all kinds of stuff that we thought
previously or I would have thought
previously was irreplaceably human
domains so in areas like art and music
and writing you're seeing AI sort of
weigh it were you know we're warm it's
way in there
so with art we went and talked to people
working on the problem of in antiquity
you have let's say Roman vases which are
very very hard to come by now because
they break obviously if you feed enough
of what we know was made in the in
ancient times into an algorithm it turns
out that it can also then kick out for
you examples that should exist because
they would connect these two examples
you know about but that no one has seen
and our DES story ins are in fact
beginning to use that missing link that
is totally digital and totally just
projected by the algorithm to predict
you know where things of where things
probably went in order to then get to
this you know period in you know in
Greece or in you know Etruscan pottery
or whatever it is it turns out that that
our taste in art and the way that we
make art is actually pretty legible to a
system like that and in fact it's so
legible now then we went and covered a
guy in London who sold a piece of AI art
at Sotheby's for $50,000 that basically
he fed his favorite 10,000 oil paintings
from the 14th to 11th century into and
it kicked back this greatest-hits piece
of art that just generates what it knows
he will find pleasing based on the
examples that he's fed it and again it's
sold for fifty thousand dollars it was a
whole article in the MIT tech review by
a philosopher saying that you know a
computer can never make real art and I
wanted to ask that guy well somebody
bought it for $50,000 so what do you
care whether it's real art somebody
totally bought it and believes it enough
to think that they should buy the thing
so I don't know for me it what's the
point of that debate in music this is
one that I thought well there's no
way it can get involved there well yeah
sure it can it turns out there's only
seven variables to music it turns out to
be the easiest of the arts to to feed in
and in faith in fact Huawei used the
technology on just its phone its little
mate phone to finish Franz Schubert's
unfinished symphony again using that
idea where the missing pieces and you
see enough of the rest of the pit of the
puzzle the missing pieces would look
like this
La Orchestra played it there and with
writing this one really blew my mind so
there's a woman named Anna Todd who was
a living a very hard life as the as an
army wife on a base with a disabled son
I mean really not having a good time and
she would sort of escape from her life
by standing in the checkout line and be
writing into her phone on a platform
called Wattpad the romance novels she
wishes were out there pretty soon she
had this crazy following this little
really loyal following on Wattpad and it
turns out what Walker does is it takes
not just the patterns that it can detect
in your writing and compares it to other
successful things like Twilight or
whatever else it also then can read the
way your audience is reacting and the
sort of the the pace and and path of
that reaction to then project what's
going to be a winner and now Anna Todd
is a is a multi-millionaire who has a
whole series called after you never
forget your first one or something about
you never after your first one anyway
she's fabulous person to talk to she
says I don't really know how this
happened but it's great and I'm really
enjoying it she now has there's a whole
Netflix series that's coming out with
her but again this is a system in which
algorithms are spotting the patterns of
what she's written comparing it to
successful stuff and green-lighting
scripts and novels based on that and
I'll tell you right now as someone who
works in media the risk aversion of
media is very strong and so if you've
got something where the it where the AI
says this script will work you know
they're gonna start they're gonna go for
that and they are so again it's just
this question of human taste being just
very easy to imitate not not perfectly
but enough to fool us and as a result
the choices we make I think are very
easy to sort of manipulate in this
fundamental way and that's because it's
all just a matter of finding and
predicting our patterns so getting back
to this this generation ship idea right
137,000 generation stuck on on on this
planet or in the ship
if you think across generations here is
the sort of the problem that I think
about or worry about is that you're
gonna have this first pass in which we
sample human taste and human activity
and the loans we make and the jobs we
offer and the sentences we hand out and
out of that sampling where the algorithm
grabs
you know these various algorithms grab
the the best examples they can and then
categorize the data and then kick out a
bunch of options we're gonna then choose
from those smaller curated options and
then live out of life you know using
those options and then we're gonna
generate a smaller data set that then
out of that then the algorithm will
analyze again and then say oh well out
of this smaller group they liked this
little chunk of it and then we're gonna
choose again and for me that leads I
worry to a sort of a collapsing cycle of
decreasing choice you know for some
people they think of you know a is sort
of facilitating this kind of endless
universe of choice and it's gonna free
us from our biases and we're gonna be
more you know freed of the tedium of
work I hope that's true but I also worry
that it's going to instead look like a
spiral staircase that goes endlessly
down as we restrict our choices and
constrict our choices and at the bottom
we're all wearing freaking beige and
drinkin Soylent you know I'm saying like
we're like that that we're not making
interesting weird random choices anymore
because the choice is given to us with
its people the store that is people
that's right so that for me is the loop
and you know now let's just talk for a
second about how we might break the loop
I have no idea how I'm doing in time and
I and where am I good okay so when I
think and I'm sorry I have to take a sip
of water here so when I think about the
sort of the you know I've been looking
for parallel domains because I find so
much of the of the scholarship and
research into this into both sort of
human behavior which I've doing a lot of
study of and I have a big PBS series
coming out about that and then the
technology that governs that behavior
you know I don't find that those groups
talk to each other very often certainly
not outside of fabulous programs like
casbahs there are a few places where
that's increasingly happening but it's
not as much as I would like and so it's
very hard to find places where people
have really tried to put these questions
together and it's even harder to find
places where then they've come up with
cuts policies that could somehow govern
the way that other technologies and
other innovations have have guided our
choices in ways that we maybe didn't
intend or didn't like but one realm
that's pretty obvious is sort of the
low-hanging fruit of my businesses
addiction we know now that it's not cool
to just turn loose the most addictive
possible stuff onto a population and
just let them sell it to each other and
do it whenever they want and that's why
we as a society have decided okay there
are certain drugs there's heroin and
cocaine and the rest of it that you you
cannot let be legal because it just
changes humanity and in fact essentially
when you talk to I was talking to people
AI researchers who were thinking about
ethics and they were saying that in fact
the heroin problem is a problem they
think about if you're gonna be a if
you're gonna build an AI that's going to
sort of amplify the best qualities of
someone analyze their behavior and then
try and suggest the best choices they
should make what if that person is
addicted to heroin and every choice that
they make is just driving back toward
that addiction should the AI be trying
to spot that and pull them away from it
or should it be trying to optimize their
path to heroin what would you do right
this is one of the problems of this kind
of binary line drawing kind of system
but addiction I think has lots of
interesting you know and this is by the
way is where it's gonna get real
loosey-goosey and I'm and I'm really
open to as many decision as many ideas
as you have and I'm excited to talk to
you about them
another one is gambling right and this
one I was hoping would have more
instructive parallel lessons for us but
it turns out when you get into the
regulations around gambling they have
far less to do with keeping ourselves
away from ourselves and and keeping life
happy and much more to do with making
sure that the state gets its cut you
know in places where it's happening and
it turns out that in fact
gambling is on the rise all across the
world and all across the country I
didn't realize that slot machines are
legal I think in 41 states right now
like so this is actually not going the
right direction in a way that it's too
bad I've been thinking quite a lot about
some of the early what they called the
action rationalists the RAND Corporation
people and others who were trying to
figure out a system that could govern
ethical decision-making once everyone is
killed at the top of the command
structure and could you somehow create a
set of hard and fast rules that would
govern the negotiation over nuclear
weapons and and how we use them and
what's interesting there is that the
fundamental lesson was no you can't
build hard and fast rules for that you
have to bring people back to a table and
talk it through you know it cannot be
you know they basically sort of said oh
my god we've almost ruined the world and
that was the whole doctor especially
Doctor Zhivago Strangelove thank you
that out the Strangelove idea right is
that you don't want hard and fast rules
you need human consciousness to come in
I think there are interesting domains in
which the the algorithm would not spot
the thing but we can all agree that it's
really important and should drive policy
so a couple of these is right now if you
buy or make a new car for the American
market you have to include a backup
camera they're mandatory now in all new
vehicles and the reason is a very small
well yeah a very small number of
children are killed by being backed over
in the driveway and in the number is
very small it's like thirty to sixty a
year it's not a big number right the
algorithm would never spot that in the
math but the person who typically runs
them over is their mom or dad right and
so a lawmaker policymaker you and I can
agree that's [ __ ] unacceptable right
and we have to build a policy that makes
that better right now there's a whole
debate going on about whether we should
also include a system that would let you
know when you've forgotten because
probably you're distracted on your phone
that your
it is in the maxi and you leave them in
there and they and the and the windows
are closed and it's a hot day we've had
again a very small number of kids died
that way but it's totally unacceptable
to society right algorithms can't help
us with that we as a society have to
agree oh yeah no that's a problem worth
regulating out of existence right but
the thing that I think is really one of
the most interesting examples is
something called the United States
versus Carroll towing company it was a
case tried in 1947 in which a tugboat
was told to untie a barge at the end of
a long line of barges in New York Harbor
and the Harbormaster and the tug mate
got out untied that that barge and
didn't realize that in doing so they had
also untied all the other intervening
barges between that and the pier those
barges broke free went all over the
harbor and one of them struck a vessel
that was full of u.s. flour flour owned
by the US government the US government
then of course prosecutes for the loss
of this flour and the the second
District Court I'm not a law guy on so I
don't know these court terms well enough
but a judge named justice learned at
hand basically realized there is no good
law on the books for what happens when a
thing that no one really is responsible
for is set loose to do all kinds of
damage and how do we figure out how to
balance out the necessity of taking
better precautions for making sure that
doesn't happen against the public risk
of this being thing being let loose and
so he came up with something called the
hand rule and it's fascinating I think
he expressed it as an equation he said
you have to balance PL against B PL is
probability of loss and the gravity of
loss how likely is this thing to happen
and how bad will it be what it happens
against be the burden of precaution the
the the cost of dealing with it ahead of
time and he basically said if the
probability of loss and gravity of loss
is greater than the burden of precaution
then it's on the company to take better
precautions so it's literally the cost
of taking precautions versus the cost of
you and I living in a world that doesn't
have them available to us and so I think
it's just a fascinating way to think
about this right because if you think of
it this way let's say you know we've we
live in a society right now where you
could have a car that never killed
anybody and it would cost millions of
dollars right it'd be festooned in all
sorts of you know explosive foams that
wooden wrap whoever at head and you and
I would be encased in foam and nobody
would ever die on the road right but we
could never afford that car on the other
hand we certainly have gotten to the
place where we found it totally
unacceptable that we occasionally very
occasionally back over a child in the
child's own driveway and so we've been
willing to change the costs on that at a
thousand bucks to the sticker price for
that we are weighing these things all
the time and society it turns out you
can do that and so for me when I look at
the possibility of weighing the turning
loose of a decision guidance system like
algorithms on to society versus the
precautions that the companies who are
purveying them and sometimes it's not
companies unfortunately but the the you
know agencies and institutions and and
all the different people were turning it
loose you know if should there be
greater precautions that they have to
take as compared to the cost to us of
living without those precautions and so
these are just a few of them that I bump
into when I talk to people the notion of
you know paying taxes on how much you
manipulate somebody right Facebook right
now puts a price on the changing of a
mind or the prompting of an action well
regulators could also people have argued
put a price on the chain on the degree
to which you're allowed to do that there
may be some way to you know tax that in
some way sharing the data making it such
that if you do open you know if you do
analyze
huge swaths of behavioral data you got
to make it open to everybody so they can
check your work and see you're doing it
ethically those kinds of things
funding counter education should be in
some way you know be preparing kids to
ignore the products that we make and
dual use designation right if you're an
anthrax researcher on the academic level
you need to go and get designated
basically licensed to do that research
because it has dual uses it can be used
for very good things and for very bad
things so all of that right could be the
burden on people who want to use this
stuff as compared to the burden on us of
living without it and those burdens are
pretty straightforward right you know
addiction the death of choice which
we've talked about here the death of
truth we're seeing with deep fake videos
in the rest of it everybody wearing
freaking beige right these are problems
that could be unleashed on society if we
sort of aren't careful and so we are I
think right now at a very primitive
stage of weighing these things against
one another just returning to United
States versus Carroll I just spent a
long time going down the rabbit hole of
maritime regulations on barges the tying
up of barges you know how frickin
complicated it is to tie up a barge
right now like the rules you got to
follow to do that there's a whole world
of stuff you got to do there's a vessel
security officer who needs to be
registered in all these crazy ways in
order to be allowed to be the person
who's even the bargee who's allowed to
be on the boat if you're gonna spend the
night on the barge forget it there's a
whole other certification for that you
know it goes on and on turns out we
learn from this stuff we learn from it
we get better at it we make policies
that can they can you know change this
stuff make us safer I think that that
there are all kinds of examples that we
can be drawing on as we build these
systems to make the kind of world that
we want to live in so when we're stuck
in these fricken tin cans together you
know we make choices now that we won't
regret you know in a generation to
generations or 2,000 generations so
thank you very much I really appreciate
it
thank you and I'm gonna start with a few
questions that are kind of in the
devil's advocates basically I know
you've thought about some of these
things and I know some of our audience
has and so yeah we're gonna I want to
talk about that I think you know one of
them is one that we talked about a
little bit before this talk and I'm
always reminded of you know when the the
printing press came out and books were
readily available and people said these
things that people were holding in their
hands and cafes would be the undoing of
social structure because no one's ever
gonna have a good conversation again or
when my generation or my parents in
recent had rock and roll or my
generation at videogames or whatever it
is and so now it's it's handheld screens
why is this different maybe you know do
we think that our next generation may
just totally ignore us and will be the
transition generation that has to deal
with the stupid part yeah you know so I
I think that's a very it's a great
question you know for me and I also
realize the total ridiculousness of the
fact that I work in television right and
I'm here critiquing this whole you know
newfangled technology but I will say
that all the way up through television
the technology has been slow enough I
mean books certainly write slow enough
that they weren't what what they were
certainly weren't doing was mutating in
response to your preferences without you
having any idea that it's happening
right and there's a hole I mentioned
briefly there's a whole other side of my
life where I talk to behavioral
researchers you know heuristics people I
have this documentary coming out next
year on PBS called hacking your mind
that's all about the ways in which we
are increasingly discovering the sort of
users manual for our brains and putting
it to all sorts of nefarious
manipulative purposes that we can't see
we can't feel them when they happen and
to me absolutely there are but right I
mean there are books that are deeply
manipulative right and are in our
difficult in that way but they are not
but they're being right written in at
such a pace that I feel like society has
had or at least developed the tools to
deal with that and talk that stuff
through right this stuff moves so fast
and learns you so quick in ways that you
certainly cannot spot that I think it's
a new category of problem and I don't I
so that's how I thought the kind of
granularity and the adaptivity
is fundamentally new which I think
that's right I think it's also important
to understand that right every other
great invention huge world-changing
invention that we've had up until now
whether it's you know nuclear weapons
even the internet right started in the
public sphere that started and got going
in either academic work or in the
government the way that algorithms are
deployed right now it's almost entirely
in the private sector in ways that in
the old days you know a journalist like
me could walk up to and learn something
about through more open public channels
right now you know you guys finding
somebody within a company that wants to
talk to me openly about what they're
doing really hard really hard
unprecedented ly hard and so and if any
of you work in one of those companies I
hope you know that I can keep secrets
very well and I've fun to hang out with
but I would just say that's another
factor there is a there was an economic
structure to the way this stuff is being
developed right now that I that also
worries me in that way yeah I think I
mean strangely one of the only public
ways you can find out how some of these
algorithms work is by trying to buy ad
space and I know even for us at long now
the the the level the the level that we
can turn the creepy dial yes is higher
than I have anywhere near comfortable of
doing that's right and I'd way rather
target incorrectly then target in ways
that are being offered to us which is
pretty stunning right and there is a
whole economy built on the idea that you
can get into someone's head you can
predict based on on what they've liked
you know what they're gonna do next and
it's and it's and it's in ways now that
human beings could never have done
before you could look at a demographic
and say you know the the categories that
a Facebook kicks out to the human eye
looked totally random but make perfect
sense when the algorithms are parsing
the data and that for me is
that's a new world in terms of
manipulative power right and I'm the
other question I have is you know if if
we're so predictable why are you worried
if we're taken out of the loop mmm
so what is what is the special people
sauce
you know what that yeah your the
equation that you talk about for
instance doesn't add up
in terms of backup cameras but we have
as you point out we have emotionally
decided to add the backup cameras they
cost more than the lawsuits probably did
but yep we have decided that we're gonna
do that just like we did with seat belts
and that's right safety glass and pretty
much every other innovation in
automobile right there are these
fabulous researchers who sort of
descended from one of the best known of
the casbahs fellows Daniel Kahneman
right who worked with Amos Tversky to
sort of pioneer this whole idea of
heuristics and how we make decisions
a lot of their graduate students and
contemporaries went on to do all kinds
of fast fascinating work and this guy
named Paul slovic
who created a whole world of learnings
around how we make decisions with our
guts with our with our emotions in this
way that is far more efficient than
actually sitting and calculating out the
answer to a thing and he has all kinds
of fascinating ways of showing you how
that's true and showing how it's
actually it's not bad it's a good thing
it's actually been quite useful and
there are amazing researchers as a this
fabulous couple called Patty and Penn
who I was introduced to I was at cazness
and and they look at like the
impossibility of squaring even the the
you know the top three things listed in
the Declaration of Independence laugh
the reason pursuit of happiness are not
compatible goals and you can't do them
as a ranked choice list like it doesn't
work there are mathematicians who break
this stuff out so it turns out there's a
squishier way that human beings make
decisions that are agreed upon by all of
us then something as simple as the cost
of a thing the monetary cost of a thing
or the resource cost of a thing there is
I think a capacity for just detecting
human you know the humans have a shared
sense of repugnance
at the death of children and at all
sorts of things that you know maybe we
can code maybe we can you know create an
algorithm that can pick those out for us
but I'm not sure we want that like I
think that part of the sort of the the
the very tenuous social fabric that
allows us to drive on a highway for
miles and miles and not cross the line
and kill the woman in the next lane you
know it's because there's this sort of
agreement among us all that we all you
know in a way that we can't even
describe are making decisions with our
emotions that line up with one another
and so you know I I bring the that hand
rule out as a way of thinking about you
know the the cost of deploying this
technology across society but I think
that in doing that P&L the probability
of lost in gravity of loss you have to
also work in things like horror you know
and not just money well I think the
other thing that happens when you know
obviously when backup cameras get
universalized you know now you can buy a
$50 backup camera and you know there's
something that you actually create the
market by making my emotional choice and
I think that's important and I think the
other factor that is kind of the the
real question that we wrestle with with
this is that you know the famous trolley
problem which is you know now in
self-driving cars of you know if a
self-driving car has to choose between
killing the toddler on the side of the
street or killing its own passenger
which every self-driving car will at
some point well not every way at some
point right nice sorry private cars will
have to make this decision
what do you how do you decide those
ethics yeah that's right and so what
humans are actually bad at that
momentary ethic decision or they're
they're highly random at least right not
only are we bad at it our whole society
is geared toward just dissecting it
later like the whole point of the court
system is not to say you know used to
say well what what should he have done
in this case and who is more at fault
than something else well we're going to
be talking about when that situation
comes up is actually subpoenaing
the internal records of the company that
say we decided ahead of time that kids
are more valuable than people or this is
more of a
that and it may be that we have some
sophisticated mature way of doing that
math you know I'm not sure but but it I
think I think we forget that our that
again this very fragile structure we've
built for ourselves is based on these
assumptions that that we just forget
about until we break them you know and
in that case the trolley problem totally
breaks it because we don't think about
that ahead of time we only do that in
retrospect in court I mean you would
think that maybe if we let's say if we
open source the trolley problem right
right
that if if we decide as a public that
the that the toddler you know that we've
recognized because it's lobbers more
than the right size size versus lover it
figures out that the toddler with dirt
that now that now we have decided that
he or she is worth more than the the
ninety five year old driver who was
driving that car based on you know all
kinds of ways you could decide that
Mehcad imagine that maybe that that's
that that society would be more
accepting of that algorithm than they
would be of the after the fact equation
maybe I mean but but what I think about
in terms of thing about this loop right
is that at the top of the loop maybe we
get to individually choose right you're
given the car and you say well I'm I've
decided that this is more the way I want
it to make decisions or that's more the
way I wanted to make decisions right at
the bottom of that loop no one gets a
choice anymore right and the and we've
all codified everything such that you
don't get to make choices again you've
taken me way out of my depth on this one
that is a really interesting question I
have I don't know the answer to that
question at all but but I I think that I
wish I could bring these this couple
Patty and Penn here because they would
just point to the impossibility of
coming up to any kind of real consensus
about which thing we think is less
horrible and more about simply
projecting the idea that there is a sort
of a legitimacy to the system that made
that decision and that's as close as you
ever get to really consensus it's just
agreeing well at least it was a
legitimate discussion they have a whole
I mean you want talk about people who'll
destabilize your you know make you
realize that we are all making this up
as we go along those two have really
blown my mind but but for me I think
that the
I you know this idea that we're gonna be
able to agree as a society on a thing
that we want an algorithm to choose each
time is not gonna work that's gonna be a
rough process I think that's a really
rough process that's right yeah and will
happen out of our control in a way that
is not good that's certainly the way
that that's happening now that's not
happening in an open source way no but
but actually I think and so we're gonna
start opening up to questions and we
have a mic out there already so I'll
just do one last one which is that yeah
I thought it was interesting that you
opened up with a with an example of a
company that's doing something that at
least some chunk of our society has
agreed as a good use yes of this
technology and you know we assume that
81% is better than the percent before
they had of arguments or something yep
and so have you come across other good
example examples of that I mean there's
a lot of them right so one of them
there's a very interesting company
called epic which is a they do
electronic health records they're the
number one provider of electronic health
records around the country and they
built for a hospital chain in Louisiana
called ochsner health a system for
ranking which patients a cardiologist
should see on her rounds based on the
probability that something bad will
happen to that patient in the next
period of time so they take all this
patient data from past cardiology
patients and they say okay and literally
she would get that the physician would
get a text to her phone that says
patient X in room five has a 80% chance
of flatlining in the LES in the next two
hours see him first right so I was
talking to them two epic antioxidant
about it and they say first of all it's
a freaking miracle it's amazing it
totally improves outcomes by this crazy
amount 40% fewer codes they call it then
before 40% fewer people wind up dying
because they're getting out in front of
stuff based on the algorithmic
probabilities this stuff fantastic
amazing so I then was reminded of
something called prospect theory and any
behavior nerds here know what that is
it's basically this notion that sort of
fundamentally collapses down to this
idea that human
are terrible at statistics and
probabilities if you give if you give us
percentages we collapse them toward much
easier percentages that we know how to
deal with and they basically figured out
that that human beings can really only
do five percentages we can do zero
percent 100 percent 99 percent one
percent and 50/50
there is no 62 percent of a thing you
know your brain goes fifth that's 5050
you know or if it's 80 percent you go up
that's ninety nine right and it helps to
explain in part why we fall for things
like travel insurance because we're
allergic it turns out to any kind of
uncertainty so we'll do anything to move
99% to 100% because we freaking hate 99%
so anyway there's this human frailty in
percentages so I asked the guys at
ochsner and an epic well how did you
pick the percentages you know do you
just deliver the rawest percentage do
you two a number what do you do and they
were like oh you know that's really
interesting that you mentioned that you
know we found that it's a real issue
when you give people too high of a
percentage they kind of overreact but if
it's too low of a percentage they react
pretty slowly and so we had to really
fine-tune how we delivered percentages I
was like oh isn't that interesting and
then they said we also I asked how many
times has a physician asked you how it
came to the conclusion it did have the
physicians ever asked why this patient
and they said one guy did once and that
was it one of all of these MDS one of
them had said how does it arrive at this
conclusion they were so thrilled to be
done with the to be able to wash their
hands of the process of choosing who's
next they were happy to let a computer
tell them to do it right so for me 40%
better fantastic fantastic doctors that
don't question what they're given
anymore if the computer says yes we're
back in the David Dow United 3 4 1 1
situation right so that release of the
decision is actually an interesting
carrot for a lot of people and it is a
wonderful thing right but and I mean you
know we all want to be we all want to
give up certain
until tasks but at what cost in the long
term that's the I mean when faced with
deciding on a restaurant in San
Francisco you coulda man maybe that's
okay how many relationships could be
saved it's funny and yet that's right
and yet there was there was a writer for
The New Yorker
AJ Liebling who blamed guide books on
the blamed the death of cuisine on
guidebooks because it's he said it made
it possible for restaurants to stay open
that never got rough repeat customers
because if as long as they had a good
review they only had to be pretty good
whereas if it was the neighborhood place
and you came back every night you'd know
in a second that they were falling apart
and you'd say eh Monsieur oh you're
doing a bad job here and so he blamed
the death of cuisine in like 1930 or
something on the Michelin guys right so
this thing of ordering choice for us
does it change the choices in a way that
we don't perhaps want right well anybody
who works in hospitality industry will
have their stories about Yelp yeah yeah
certainly tell you that but I think you
know if you make the right version of
that then you could probably then know
which people are about to get divorced
or not yeah and you could feed it to the
other totally and let's be clear I
travel for a living and I use Yelp like
crazy like I'm I am devoted to the use
of that thing I totally yeah so I get it
it's good it's good in many ways but
what's all it's horrible also as a buddy
who runs right right hospitality
industry yes so sorry we have a question
over here and ER there are many examples
before the rise of AI of algorithms
going seriously wrong like something
like redlining
where you know an algorithm decided who
got who got the loans and a led to like
generations of poverty that we're still
struggling with today right now that
we're finally having a conversation
about this do you think there's a
possible future where we can actually
just build our ethics into the
algorithms and just make a choice of
society and just say like well no we're
not going to decide based on what all
the basically the training data that
already exists but basically put
prescriptive instructions into the
the rhythms and sort of shift them to
not just reflect the reality that has
already been here that's so imperfect
but to create the reality that we want
so I was talking to a company that was
doing exactly what you're describing
they were giving loans out and they were
trying specifically to avoid redlining
right which the practice of designating
certain neighborhoods and you know
basically making it such that black
people could not or music color could
not live in certain places they were
trying to do away with that they were
trying to get on the right side of
history and they did it by or they
thought they were doing it by removing
the traditional data that one would use
to red line so they they pulled out
things like where do you live which was
a traditional way zip codes was a way of
redlining back in the day they removed
everything that they could think of
names all kinds of stuff that they that
they thought would perhaps reflect and
pull in the racism of the system because
they wanted to get on the right side of
history at the end of the first year of
doing that they looked at their
statistics and because they were
preparing to present them to Elizabeth
Warren's agency helped me out consumer
banking fraud protection thank you thank
you whatever it is and they found
looking at the data that in fact the
loans they had made were more racist
than ones made using the traditional
racist data right and they realized
something that I think you you are also
realizing by by your question right and
that everybody I hope is I'm encouraged
on some level by this that it's not
about making the data as neutral as
possible it is in fact perhaps about
putting your thumb on the scale in some
places and trying to write historical
wrongs maybe there is some sort of
putting it in in the same way that we
decide against the math that we do need
backup cameras on all our cars right so
so maybe maybe that is the thing of
course then you need to convince the
country or at least in the moment we're
in right now the leadership of a company
that it is important
to write the historical wrongs of
redlining and that there is
institutional racism in the country that
is creating tremendous structural
imbalances you know then you get into a
whole other sort of question of it but
yes I do like the idea of that I am I
would be happier with that if that
wasn't happening inside of companies
that don't talk to anyone outside of the
company about what they're doing because
as much as I am pleased personally to
see you know the that social justice is
cool now I'd like to remind everyone
that there have been vast periods of
history where it is not cool to be woke
you know like there and there and we
could just as easily go back that way
right the arc of history is long but it
bends toward justice is that famous
saying well I would like to point out
that you know lots of people pointed out
to me when you talk to behavioral
scientists they're such a bummer to hang
out with because they say things like we
don't actually know how long the arc of
history is because we've only been in it
for this long and we have no idea which
way it bends right so for me I like you
know I'm glad that people feel a moral
responsibility to make good choices
within companies and I often get that
line from people that I talk to within
those companies but I don't think that's
enough to build something as important
as where people get to live on so that's
that's my concern about so yes I hope we
continue to push things in the right
direction I'd like some structural
things to change in the process we have
the mic in the back of the room yeah
Jacob make you so much for that talk it
was fantastic thank you I especially
appreciated all of the tension that got
built over the course of the talk as we
started to realize what algorithms were
doing to our life as it would kind of
replaced our own decision-making
structure but I couldn't help but notice
at the end we all kind of landed on
another representational algorithm with
the hand rule and we all could have
breathed a sigh of relief and the
tension was released and we thought okay
cool now we can actually make this
decision a little bit easier right but I
wonder if in researching the hacking
your mind series have you run into any
philosophers or psychologists or even
like a theologian who's who've advocated
that the anxiety of decision-making is
actually more of a feature and not a bug
and that we shouldn't perhaps try to
solve it and get rid of it
yes so thank you for that that is such a
thoughtful question I I wish you had
been with me yesterday when I showed
this to my co-workers and they said
here's how you can make it better you
would he would have been very helpful
then you know so yes so I have a whole
other talk that I maybe someday I can
come here and and and give about right
they the Kahneman idea of system 1 and
system 2 which he built out of a whole
body of scholarship that had come before
him and it it had to do with this fast
thinking brain and the slow thinking
brain you know his book Thinking Fast
and Slow which sort of tries to
articulate this but but basically the
notion that there is a very ancient
decision-making system that we share
with all of our primate cousins still to
this day and researchers have shown this
and I in fact got to go and watch
monkeys do this on this cool island
puerto rico and it turns out that for
more than 30 million years at least 30
million years because that's where we
intersect with primates we have had this
system that is all about instinctive
decision-making it's emotions like we
were talking about it is external
stimulus making your decision for you
and what Kahneman first means so many
other people pointed out is that that
system that ancient decision-making
system is kind of mismatched with the
modern world because when you are
currently you know when you walk into an
environment the stimulus of that
environment makes your decision for you
so for me as a non-drinker right when I
walk into a bar my whole business is
like oh you'd now's the time to start
drinking right because that's the
decision-making system that it that that
I inherited then there is another
decision-making system the slow thinking
system that's really only about you know
maybe 140,000 years old maybe 70,000
years old they don't really know but
it's a very new very glitchy system that
is where our creativity comes from and
our ability to reason and the ability to
sit still here and you know not take all
my clothes off and run around you know
like all of the higher functioning of
our bodies and of our minds is a very
recently evolved system and what so many
of these folks in talking to them for
hack in your mind say is you really need
them both like we would be exhausted if
we had to use our higher
for everything and yet if we use only
the fast thinking brain system one then
you get I mean they they're these
terrifying experiments that they showed
us where you know you flash you flash
pictures of faces past people too fast
for them to identify any single face and
then afterwards and in doing so they
have to choose I'm gonna screw up the
description of this but they have to
choose which one is more likeable of the
two and they and and then something
about which one is more symmetrical to I
can remember this but anyway you're very
quickly making decisions of comparing
faces and at the end of it they reveal
that those aren't just random snapshots
of people they're actually candidates
for state office over the past ten years
and it turns out that all the ones you
chose are the ones that won right
because it turns out that our system won
our fast thinking brain is going into
the booth right and casting votes on
this leg you know kind of way this sort
of ancient primate way and so we need
the slower harder you know more
difficult thinking style in order to
make good decisions for this totally
invented reality we have built for
ourselves where we wear shoes and drink
coffee and hang out right so so what do
we you know how do we balance those two
things out I'm not sure but I will say
no one's making money off the slow
thinking everyone's making money off the
fast thinking and so every business
every political campaign every
manipulative you know activity out there
is aiming at your primate brain and
trying to get you with it and so yes we
have to keep the slow thinking brain
sacred and maybe there's a way through
algorithms right maybe there's a way
there maybe there's a Yelp of the future
that accesses your your slow thinking
brain there's a family this guy
connected to cosmos named Tino Cuellar
who's a federal judge he talks about a
system an idea that he calls weak
perfection which is only a big deal in
law circles where they basically the the
system is designed to make it a total
pain in the ass to do certain things and
one of them is enter a plea if you're
going to make a choice about
whether you're pleading guilty or
innocent you you you got to golike
through five different steps and you got
to show up in person it's like a total
pain and people have over the years
always said well we got to make that
easier got to make it easier well no
they say no we don't cuz you're never
getting to make that choice again and
when you do make it it's make it's
having an incredibly huge impact on your
life so we have to keep your slow
thinking brain involved to make this
correct so so I think there are many
many examples in which we know you've
got to defend like you say the heart you
know the the hard work of making
difficult choices and my worry is that
there are so many billions of dollars
being spent to take that initiative away
from you we had room for one more I was
struck by your example of the the guy
being pulled off the plane and not
having kind of ability to engage in that
and it reminded me of something that
Stuart brand said on the on our summit a
few years ago about long-term thinking
it's one of the more I'm gonna
paraphrase it badly and wrong probably
but one of the things said more the more
we think about long term thinking the
more turns out it's not actually the
solutions or the particular technologies
they're important but it's all these
other human qualities that we really
need to develop and so what makes me
worry in the picture presenting is it's
we're still talking all about decisions
and making decisions but you know and is
that accelerating the quashing of all
the development or attention to other
human qualities that sort of are
important in the unknowns that come
forward so my question is and sort of
follow-up to what you were just talking
about I mean what are the human
qualities that you now would worry are
either being lost or should be promoted
in in you know in sort of the realm well
there's one of the first things to go
beyond just the you know we need time
for irrational minds but if we were more
specific about what what are the real
things yeah we could lose or that we
could emphasize yeah god that cause
makes me so tired I I want I want an
area we have a bar full of drinks for
you yeah good thank you yes thank you
thank thank you sister more
thank you fasting brain you know I I'm a
great and I mean I I know I'm a total
downer to listen to but I
I actually am incredibly optimistic and
pleased with human history and when my
wife and I was here tonight
you know first got together we were
trying to reconcile the difference in
our pasts where we we we you know she'd
grown up in the church and I'd grown up
in a sort of a household that very
actively rejected the notion of the
church and yet I threw her you know got
to sort of see the power of human beings
being connected to one another through
something like the church and you know
we lived in a community for instance
where all of these norms had obviously
come out of this shared experience such
that for instance it was not okay not to
say good morning and good afternoon to
everybody you know I came I came from a
society where everybody kind of walks by
each other very quietly and and my wife
taught me like oh no you want to be
accepted here you got to talk to
everybody yeah say good morning and you
guys say good afternoon and she was
right when I sort of you know I take
that as sort of an example of how
through you know there's a wonderful
researcher at Harvard named mahzarin
banaji and she starts every talk not
every talked about she for a while there
started every talk by saying I'd like to
congratulate you on being the most
diverse group of people in human history
to ever sit in one room and no one's
gonna die today
you know great job right that that for
some reason we actually in spite of the
political moment that we're living in we
have a tremendous ability for cohesion
we're great at connecting to one another
right and and inspiring one another and
loving one another and being loyal to
one another against all logic you know
so for me the power of human association
and networking you know the ways in
which we pass things on to one another
man I could go on forever but I mean
I'll just give you this one example
there's a fabulous this researcher who
looks at people who've lost their
eyesight the the
are they are consciously blind but the
mechanism of their eye is still intact
it's just severed from the brain and and
she has shown that they can these people
who have what she calls blind sight can
be shown certain stimulus and even
though they can't consciously see it
they react to it and she had this famous
case where she thought this guy couldn't
see anything she brought him into the
lab they were hanging out and just to
mess around with him cuz they weren't
having any success that day they set up
a little obstacle course in front of him
the guy is blind he shows up with a cane
he can't see she puts him in this thing
and she says can you walk to the other
end of the room and he walks along and
avoids all the obstacles and we have
footage of it in the PBS special where
he goes around the obstacle at the end
of it everybody at them and all these
researchers gasped and they're like oh
my gosh how did you do that and he says
do what he has no idea that his not only
was he perceiving the stuff in his way
but his body was moving around it he has
no idea that was happening she then went
on to do research on him and other
people showing that in fact if you show
them pictures of people making big
smiles or you know big frowns or looking
horrified you ask them what do you see
and they say I'm blind you idiot can't
you see you know can't you tell I have a
cane like I can't see anything but it
turns out that if you attach all sorts
of sensors to their face they can detect
the micro musculature movements of their
faces when you show them a person
smiling their face starts to smile when
you show in person
screaming they start to do that same
thing we are born to catch emotions we
have an unconscious apparatus for
catching emotions from each other and
passing it on to the next person and it
probably had some great evolutionary
function monopile in spawn time where
the room catches fire and I make a mask
of horror and then Xander makes a mask
of horror and then everybody's
horrifying we all get the [ __ ] out
without having to say the rooms on fire
right but it also means we're built or
not supposed to be the rooms on facts
not in fire yeah the room is not on fire
but we are built to catch and
transmitted between each other in a way
that I think is beautiful and has led to
all kinds of amazing stuff and so I want
to keep that alive my you know the
short-term worry is that we're not
talking to each other that Oberer thing
where you don't have to talk to the
driver if you don't want to you get to
silence them you know you can literally
say don't no talking on this ride that's
not good for society you know we're good
at being together and I want more of
that well I want to thank you very much
I think there's probably in a way no
topic more resonant too long now as to
how we not only make these decisions but
I think how we are gonna build the
systems of making these decisions
there's no way that something like
climate change or hunger or the prison
reform or whatever happens without us
thinking at a scale that is beyond
ourselves and I really want to thank you
for that and you get a long challenge
join as one of our speakers please round
of applause thank you very much
[Music]